i've actually got a bit of a soft spot
for teachers i used to go out with the
teacher and she was lovely
but if everyone wanted sex she always
insisted to put my hand up first
so i'm totally pro teachers [ __ ] the
kids i'll tell you what look i'm very
i'm not okay with it i'm pro i'm
doubling down
i'm doubling down on it i'll tell you
why
i looked up these little psychos that
shoot up the schools you know these
little psychopaths
right every single one of them said they
did it for the same reason
not because of bullying by the way they
said they did it because they weren't
getting late
we got a question we need to ask
ourselves guys
are these teachers monsters are they
heroes
forget no child left behind suck a dick
save a school
that's a slogan yes yes
we got to keep our babies safe
we got any female teachers in the
audience tonight
i hope you're willing to go the extra
mile
i'm not joking you see a weird kid
during lunch you know what a weird kid
the kid whose jeans don't touch his
sneakers
you see one of those hovering jeans kids
in the corner twisting a squirrel's head
off his shoulders
suck that kid's dick
empty balls make safe halls
[Applause]
how can you teach 64 kids you take the
register and then the [ __ ] bell would
go
imagine dealing with 64 primary school
kids
one is hard enough i was helping my
little cousin with his homework the
other day and i went if you had nine
apples
in one hand and five in the other what
would you have
he looked we went massive han
do you talk about your childhood a lot
because i was reading about you the
other day and
when you were in high school your father
was your homeroom teacher
oh yeah probably in grade school yeah
how was he was he mean
and strict he was a tough guy yeah yeah
he was tough
he was tough he was uh it was odd he uh
he uh didn't graduate from uh school
himself
because he was old when he had me he was
like 50. so he was in world war ii yeah
and so you know he's in the grove in the
depression and then he went to world war
two and then he came back and they said
oh we have this special thing you'd be a
teacher you know
we only had like a grade nine education
and they let him be a teacher
well he was teaching grade five so he
was highly overcome
uh professor wants to bang
hey bill i'm a 19 year old male college
freshman and my professor wants to have
sex
do it
i'm sorry that wasn't me there was
somebody else yelling okay i'm gonna be
a professional
i kept getting these signs ever since
the first few weeks of class began
you're 19. you're an adult right i'm not
really i can't get in trouble here right
um i noticed anytime i am running late
to class by a few minutes she would
always wait for me to start
class dude get to the good part what
does she look like
um every time i walked in she would say
things like oh i was worried you were
sick
and i was worried you were going to miss
my class jesus she's putting it out
there right in front of the whole class
um anytime any anyone else is late to
class she ignores them and starts on
time
well wait a minute dude are you the
teacher's pet you know when she says
so did everybody do the reading last
night do we uh
have any any thoughts on the um
assigned material everyone just sits
there staring at her chewing that gum
slowly and you actually put your
your hand up oh michael what do you have
to say
i i found it i thought it was brave i
thought it was it was exquisite
you know all right let me just read the
rest of us here um anytime
anyone else is late to clash she ignores
them starts on time okay
she is always over the top nice to me
when we see each other
i brushed this off and i didn't let it
get big in my head
all right so he sees he's like he's not
thinking that it's going to happen okay
a telltale sign came to me one day when
i was small
i was at the smoking section on the
campus after i left her class
i cheated word for word from the girl
that sits next to me in class on a test
i had just finished the girl that sits
next to me came down to the smoking
section with the bag of chocolate
in her hand and gave it to me she told
me our professor gave it
to her to give to me
yeah boy dude trying to bang your
teacher
is like trying to get away with a murder
the more people who are involved the
bigger chance you have of getting caught
so what the [ __ ] is she giving this girl
chocolate for
bringing her in the fall [ __ ] she wants
a threesome
right is this what this is where is this
where it's going please tell me it's
going in this direction
it's like a red shoe diary here um i
asked the girl if our professor gave the
chocolate to the class when i left and
she said no
i tried to keep calm
i thought you would say as my dick was
filling up i tried to keep calm and
asked the girl how she did on the test
um i told her i copied her word for word
and she said she thinks she did okay
a few minutes later a professor came
down to the smoking section
where her car was parked the girl asked
the professor what
what she made and the professor tells us
she made a 74.
when i asked her she flipped her hair
smirked at me
and told me i made a 94.
wow okay i'm gonna tell you right now
right [ __ ] now if this happens dude
you wear two condoms this woman is
reckless okay
go ahead and bang your [ __ ] teacher
do it towards the end of the semester
that's so bad anyways she's 36 years old
and divorced
um on this certain website
where evidently people can uh basically
rate their teachers
the students rated her as hot
i want to ask her out to lunch sometime
dude she's 36.
just [ __ ] her she doesn't want to go to
lunch she's 36 she wants lunch she'll
buy her own lunch but that's you know
you're 19.
i keep forgetting that anyways the only
reason why i haven't asked her out yet
is because she told me she has a 13 year
old daughter
we oh that's just under her vagina she
already had a kid
mike my question to you is would it be
wrong
there are other girls i have met but
they are the typical dumb [ __ ] you
find in college
okay all of them
i wouldn't think every girl is a dumb
[ __ ] is every guy a dumb jock
is every jock dumb see what happens when
we talk in absolutes
um i am not saying i want to marry this
broad just a one-night stand
with the history the professor would be
nice
i am not the type of guy that likes to
go around and and [ __ ] as many girls as
i meet
that is why i keep thinking that she has
that she has a daughter and i should
probably stay away what do you think
um
i don't know dude
the fact that you had it that you don't
want to [ __ ] do it i
i don't know
well listen do you know how to bang a
girl
and then [ __ ] see her the next day
and have it all be cool that that's a
skill you know
and not have her feel like you used her
or whatever
you know do you know how to do that
i can tell you one thing you don't want
to do is what i would do was was the
next day i'd be like hey
oh [ __ ] weird and then they get mad
and the next thing you know all their
friends are [ __ ] looking at you like
you're a douche and they start drawing
writing [ __ ] on your locker that's a
[ __ ] nightmare um
if you've mastered the art on how to
[ __ ] somebody and not be yeah i don't
you know something dude
if you're gonna [ __ ] this girl you have
to do it
at the end of the semester once it's
over
um this girl she's reckless she's a
nightmare
if she's [ __ ] putting this out it's
unbelievably unprofessional she should
be way more discreet
all right and you cheated on this girl
word for word she gave you 20 points
higher
you know what dude stay away from this
girl this girl is is she's gonna get
[ __ ] pregnant
and you don't want it to be you all
right who doesn't want to [ __ ] a teacher
everybody does but you know something
you don't want to have a [ __ ]
i wouldn't do it i wouldn't do it don't
do it
don't do it stay away why don't you go
meet some nice girls and stop talking to
dumb [ __ ]
and uh you know
i don't know rub one out before you go
to class and really think about it and
then let me know what happens okay